at this time I have the honor of
introducing our keynote speaker dr. mark
bracket dr. bracket and I have worked
together for some time on social and
emotional intelligence for students for
everyone actually he's improved mind
some dr. bracket comes to us from Yale
he is the executive director of the
Center for emotional intelligence at
Yale he is a believer in developing the
whole child and I also believe that
obviously I want high test scores I want
great student achievement but I know
that great student achievement cannot
calm and be sustained without developing
the social and emotional well-being of
all of the children and so this is the
culture and the foundation that I want
to bring to Bridgeport schools while I'm
here it's important it's not a soft
skill it's something that we need to
build on and then we will get that
student achievement that we want dr. a
bracket is I'm honored because he's not
only a Connecticut wide person he is
national and he's international millions
of students have been involved in this
ruler program which he will explain to
you we hope to roll it out in Bridgeport
and during the school year we are going
to take it very slow and very deep it is
not another program it
is in fact a culture that all of us will
subscribe to I tried it in my former
district I used it for three years the
suspensions and the bullying rate were
cut in half if not more I also know that
mark is incredibly talented and has been
cited by the Ziggler foundation he's
been awarded by the Ziggler foundation
and right now believe it or not he's
working with facebook on two projects a
large-scale study to prevent into crease
bullying and the second is an online
bullying prevention center for children
so please welcome to the podium dr. mark
bracket good morning I feel like I feel
like I've made it right it's sort of
like hello bridge part so Fran thank you
for the invitation to speak with all of
you and let's take the Sun a little bit
of a ride so we have a center at Yale we
call the center for emotional
intelligence it's very simple our goal
is to use the power of emotional
intelligence to create a more healthy
effective and compassionate society and
what we do are two things we do research
and we develop innovative approaches to
work with schools and what I thought
we'd do really today is make this it's
going to be hard but I'm going to try it
a bit interactive can ask everyone to
please set up straight and his or her
seats get some good posture you'll they
say you'll live longer if you have good
posture I don't have the research to
support that but nevertheless and can I
ask everyone to just take a deep breath
I just let it go it's like that song
right let it go let it go like I'm kind
of letting go my anxiety and frustration
the parking this situation I should I
can tell you that I could analyze
Bridgeport schools by watching the
teachers getting their parking spots so
please just take a moment and just relax
and what I'd like you to do for a moment
is take a little roller coaster ride
with me and think about one of your
students from last year I'd like you to
take a student into your mind's eye that
maybe had a challenging year I can you
just grab that student please and put
them into your brain and just go on a
roller coaster ride with me please it's
five o'clock in the morning and this
student wakes up how does this kid feel
when he wakes up in the morning
nourishing breakfast not nourishing
breakfast good relationships with
parents not good relationships think of
the commute to school is this kid
thinking oh my goodness this is going to
be a great day or is this kid saying to
himself yikes another day entering the
school building how does it feel for
that child to enter school feedback from
teachers no feedback friendships no
friendships difficult tests no tests
lunch time eating alone or with others
feeling connected or alienated how about
the afternoon more tests more feedback
more courses and then think about the
afternoon what does it look like for
this child after school dinner time
evening time when this child is putting
his or her head to the pillow what is he
or she thinking I can't wait for
tomorrow or do I really have to go to
sleep do I really have to get up on the
one do I really have to go to this place
tomorrow
and I don't want to have you do that to
depress all of you but what I want us to
think through hopefully for the next 20
or so minutes is why emotions matter and
why they matter for five things one is
attention memory and learning so I can
tell you from my own experience you know
right now I'm have the privilege and
honor to be in front of you but when I
was in Middle School in New Jersey I was
one of those kids who got bullied a lot
and when I think back about what I
learned in middle school it wasn't very
much at all because I couldn't be
present what we know from our research
is that emotions are driving students
attention their capacity to learn so if
you're highly stressed guess what your
brain is thinking how am I going to get
help where are my resources your brain
is not available for learning decision
making does that child who you were
thinking about make the best decisions
good quality relationships is that child
perhaps on a path to having mental
health problems and just in general is
that child effective so there is hope
and the hope is that what we know from
our work is that if we teach these kids
and the adults involved in their lives
the skills of emotional intelligence
there is a chance for success so what I
hope to share with you over the next few
years are these skills of recognizing
emotions for example i'm looking at all
of you in the audience here and i'm
getting really worried like what's going
on our people here they not hear
everybody seems to be warm and hot I'm
sweating I'm thinking about taking off
my jacket and clothes well I won't that
was a freudian slip I think I might have
been a Freudian slip so I'm trying to
read my own emotion trying to read your
emotions I'm trying to understand where
are they coming from like why is this
child angry or sad or disappointed
giving that child a vocabulary to
describe his or her emotions how to
express them in socially appropriate
ways and certainly how to regulate them
so what we know from our research is
that kids with higher emotional
intelligence have different lives they
have less anxiety they have
depression they're less likely to abuse
drugs and alcohol they're also less
likely to be aggressive and bullying
other kids well we also know are
positive things about them they have
greater leadership skills they're more
attentive and less hyper active in
school and they perform better
academically now interestingly enough we
have the opportunity to work with
teachers like yourselves and have shown
the teachers with higher emotional
intelligence guess what you're more
positive about school of greater support
from principals just for curiosity how
many of you when you think about it like
to be around the angry disgruntled
bitter colleague how many of you over
summer break said that's the person I
want to go on vacation with my hunch is
probably not we like we like to be
around people who display right positive
emotions it just makes life easier we've
also had the privilege of studying
classrooms and show that classrooms
where there is greater emotional climate
have students who just are more engaged
learners they have better relationships
they behave better and of course they
perform better academically now a big
question has come up from our researches
like can you learn these skills and when
I've learned our two things one is
everybody's got nature right we were
born by someone so i was born in a
family of two parents who were good
parents but they had no emotional
intelligence so my mother for example
when i came home with my problems would
say things like this don't tell me i'll
have a breakdown right so i was like wow
that's interesting mom you'll have a
breakdown I'm 13 but you know I'm the
one who's having the breakdown so like
can we talk about this maybe in 20 years
I'll have some strategies so we also had
my father who was a good guy also with
something like this get to your room way
to your mother gets home
right yeah that's how much she has a
breakdown this is this is really great
so that was my kind of emotional
intelligence training in life and people
wonder why I run around the world
talking about why emotions matter and
then you also have your biology right
your personality like I'm an anxious
kind of guy is anyone here a little
anxious right your teachers you got to
be a little bit worried right you know
worry nothing goes right I even worry
about why I worry and then I even have
this new thing I worry about why I worry
about why I worry because I really don't
have anything to worry about but what
the heck just worried anyway so what's
interesting is that there are skills
that we can teach everyone and my hope
is that from preschool to high school
actually from womb to tomb we can teach
children these skills and I want to take
a moment and ask you to think about your
emotional development how much education
did you receive on recognizing emotions
regulating emotions did you grow up in a
family where your parent might have said
something like this good morning honey
it looks like you might be a little bit
anxious let me give you some
research-based strategies to help you
regulate anybody have that you know I
don't think so you know emotional
intelligence is kind of a new phenomenon
that we've just been able to define and
measure and now teach so what I want to
share with you very briefly is what we
do in schools and my hope is that we
need to move away from bullying
prevention I'm actually the anti anti
bullying guy because I don't think
making rules or holding assemblies or
monitoring the hot spots or enforcing
consequences or using zero tolerance
policies or even counting on bystanders
is really the way to go I can tell you
when I was a kid I was I'm introverted
and a little bit timid so the thought of
having to help someone else out was
pretty scary and my hope is that we can
teach kids and adults the skills so that
we don't have to rely on bystanders what
we can do is make our schools places
where kids feel safe warm effective etc
and I hope we can move to over the next
few years is recognizing that the
targets the perpetrators and the
bystanders all need skill development
that we as adults needed I can tell you
I'm still working on my emotional
intelligence if you came home with me
and asked my family about my emotional
intelligence you learn that there is the
public self and the private self anybody
like that here my guess is that's
probably the case so my hope is that
we'll be able to do in bridgeport
working first with our leaders is teach
them skills and tools and there are four
tools that we have as you can see up
front and I'm going to go through this
very quickly one is that it's moving
away from rules and really focusing on
feelings so I haven't even asked you
how's everybody feeling all right that's
not a that's not good feedback by the
way how's everybody feeling yeah all
right I mean give me some support here
man so what we want to do is move away
from having rules and really focus on
asking students about their feelings how
do you want to feel working in
bridgeport I mean I asked all of you
that think about it how do you want to
feel working in this school district my
hunch is that you want to feel things
like respected how many of you want to
feel respected yeah how many of you want
to feel supported how many of you want
to feel safe motivated appreciate it
enthusiastic I mean it list goes on so I
think if we use the lens of emotion and
feelings instead of rules we'll get to
the kind of environments that we all
want in our schools and this is what
these charters look like in high schools
they look like little treatise in
elementary school here's an example this
is a
one from fifth grade they want to feel
included confident respected appreciated
energetic safe supported enthusiastic
here's one from a preschool where
they're learning in spanish and they say
they want to feel content though they
want to feel happy as padala respected
and gary though loved think about it
four year old they want to feel loved I
want to feel love to it work the second
tool is called the mood meter it's the
tool that my hope you will find so
important to your self awareness that
you'll run to the local tattoo parlor
perhaps and get one of these so you can
always be checking in with your feelings
so when a school of you to just take a
moment and think about how you're
feeling I know you're hot so let's just
like let it go let it go and think about
what's going on for you right here and
your mind's eye about the new year
you're about to start school yellow is
high-energy Pleasant feelings like
hopeful optimistic how many of you were
in the yellow raise your hand okay how
many of you were in the green you're
feeling calm kind of ready people in the
green now the blue and the red are
difficult right because red is
high-energy and unpleasant so my hope is
that none of you were there today though
you might be and blue is low energy
unpleasant words like down disappointed
hopeless despair depressed and hopefully
we can avoid those feelings this year as
well so when we do this work with
schools what we do is well actually
before we go there I'd like all of you
to take a moment and think about
honestly the word the best feeling word
that describes how you're feeling right
now just put the word into your mind
take three seconds two one freeze raise
your hand if you had a little challenge
finding the right word put your hand up
high hands up really high
really high like stretch out so a good
half of the room right we have trouble
finding those words and we're all
educated adults imagine what it's like
for that kindergartner or preschooler so
in our work what we do is work with kids
to help them identify what emotions look
like in these different quadrants what
is the body language how do people sound
what does it feel like on the inside and
how do they behave as you can see here
there are a lot of words to describe
emotions maybe 2000 in the English
language dictionary most of us use for
right you're in the yellow you feel
great green fine blue you don't use
words right red you're pissed actually
it's interesting i live in new haven now
and I'm come from the New York area I
realized that people don't even have
emotions where I live nobody even
responded say how you feeling it's like
like why would you want to know how I
felt we also want to teach kids
strategies I'm asking you a big question
right now how many of you feel like your
lives as teachers would be easier you'd
have less stress and burnout if your
students had more strategies to regulate
their feelings raise your hand yeah how
many of you be healthier and happier if
your significant others had more
strategies regulating their family
yeah it's my figure it's home at work we
know that right so we wanted to educate
all these kinds of strategies how to use
positive self-talk how to think about
someone who inspires them to get in the
yellow how to manage or get in to that
green to feel more calm and content and
relaxed and when they're feeling in the
blue how can they put a different spin
on it how can they reframe now you can
see this in a classroom would look like
this there are apps for kids there are
ways of integrating it into the
curriculum like having a student do some
problem-solving about a character in a
book and really thinking through the
emotions of the character and we even
now have an appt out where you can plot
yourself until your heart's delight so
you can plot yourself and learn you know
why are you feeling this way and learn
strategies to regulate it now when asked
all of you to take a moment and just
read this quote
between stimulus and response there is a
space in that space lies our freedom and
power to choose our response in our
response lies our growth freedom so how
many of you think that maybe prolonging
that space might help us be a little
healthier and happier that having more
strategies might be a way out and my
hope is that over the next few years we
can shift the way kids are dealing with
their emotions even some of us as adults
right moving from yelling to maybe
taking some deep breaths moving from
negative self-talk I can't do this I
hate my life why am I here too I can do
this I'm going to take the high road
from blaming to reframing from
procrastination to achieving ones goals
from rumination to positive
visualizations from avoidance to finding
good support from other people and from
pushing and shoving and beating to
problem solving how many of you feel
like that might be a good thing thank
you
but it doesn't just come naturally you
need tools I need tools and what I want
to share with you is one tool that we've
worked on for a number of years we call
it the meta moment and there are six
steps to this tool to help us regulate
our emotions more effectively and what I
can promise you is that if you take
these six steps seriously you can avoid
the 12 steps later but sorry for that so
the first is something happens how many
of you have triggers anybody have
triggers triggers from students and
colleagues administrators parents were
all triggered I was triggered this
morning I mean on my right here that
traffic trying to get into this parking
lot I'm thinking like this is ridiculous
isn't yeah you know I got a refrain I'm
and I'm being filmed today so we're all
triggered something happens step two is
that we need to make sense of those
triggers we got to teach kids like that
trigger is going to influence you in
ways that are maybe not helpful it's
going to make you think a lot of things
that maybe we'll get you in trouble you
might behave in a certain way your body
is going to get really tense and
uncomfortable the third step is we want
to teach people how to breathe let's try
that together this is like an
opportunity of a lifetime for me get
3,000 people to take a deep breath
together can we all do that please just
take one breath and let it go and just
let it go step four is called see your
best self it's interesting right see
your best self see your best possible
cell can I ask all of you to take a
moment and visualize your best self
think about yourself when you go to work
this week what adjectives will describe
you when you are at your best what's the
word that you would want your students
to use to describe you if they were
interviewed about you what kind of
person you want to be what kind of
outcomes you want what do you want your
reputation to be
like my hunch is it something like
compassionate caring creative and what
we found in our research is that when
you teach kids and adults to activate
their best selves they choose more
effective strategies it's interesting
they just do and finally there more
successful in their interactions now one
other thing we want to do is go from me
to we we want to help kids build
perspective-taking how many of you feel
like kids these days black a little bit
of empathy and perspective taking and
that it might be a good idea to teach
them to think about the others emotions
and other people's circumstances so let
me wrap up by saying there's really good
research to support this work that what
we know is that when schools adopt us
work seriously they have kids who are
less anxious and depressed there are
better problem solvers they have greater
leadership skills experienced your
attention learning problems perform
better academically and of course the
classrooms and schools become more
positive places and my personal goal by
the way is to create national policy on
this I think that every child deserves
an education and social emotional
learning because I didn't get it and
so you're going to help support that
just so you know one fun thing that
we're doing is this year we decided that
we have to partner with someone who
actually can make things happen so we're
working with Lady Gaga and we're going
to put on seriously so we're starting
what we're calling an emotion revolution
and I hope you're all part of it and the
reason why we're doing that is because
one we know that children are wired for
good if there's just great research to
support that and if attach them it's at
home and at school are positive they're
going to thrive the second thing is that
our children's ability to reach their
full potential is really ours to nurture
or to neglect and hopefully I've
convinced you in this very short
presentation that providing children
adults with this kind of emotional
intelligence training will help them
just be a healthier more effective and
productive students and make a more
compassionate society so I want to wrap
up by saying one thing I've spent 20
years of my life trying to think about
how do you make this work and it's
really hard right we're trying to go
into systems like Bridgeport Connecticut
that have have three thousand teachers
20,000 kids and what we know is that it
takes a village and my hope is that over
the next three years with our support
with the support of your superintendent
with the support of the community we can
really make a difference in the lives of
these kids and I'm going to ask all of
you to just take one sort of last breath
with me and imagine the world in 2016 a
year from now imagine what it would feel
like working in your school if children
had more strategies to regulate their
emotions there are more self-aware they
had better quality relationships their
families were more involved in their
lives and teaching these skills at home
and I hope you see kind of what I saw
and as James Heckman said it who is a
Nobel laureate the greatest returns on
education investments are from nurturing
childers non-cognitive skills things
like emotional intelligence because
that's what's going to lead to
success in life I really appreciate your
attendance your time appreciated one
hundred percent thank you very much